the year 2003 the problem there's a
photo of Barbara Stan's house on the
internet the solution sue the
photographer for $50 million and demand
the photo be removed sounds like a great
idea with the best of intentions what
could possibly go wrong it turns out
when you try and hide something people
get interested the aerial image part of
a larger project to document Coastal
erosion had only been downloaded six
times before strand got upset but in a
month follow following the lawsuit over
400,000 people clicked on the image of
Stan's house bab's loster case was
forced to pay
177,000 illegal fees and the Strand
effect is now shorthand for bringing
unwanted attention to the very thing
being suppressed maybe next time don't
mention it